I had police at my house the Pieces come
regular and just say oh it's a domestic
I need this leave I need to hang in a
minute you're supposed to take him with
you
I never did
the only most you're going to get out of
it social services so back then it
wasn't even that no but you didn't even
get that back there was nothing then I
mean I I didn't have my son then when I
did have my son on my foot that's it I'm
out of there yeah but it's like
especially when things happen around his
family not yours and that's the weird
thing is you fit yourself how can you
have a family and they know what's going
on but they won't do anything and then
you realize that the whole family's
scared of them yeah that's what I think
I was gonna